he's the quarterback consultant for the
quarterback summit former QB in the
National Football League
Jordan Palmer good to see you sir thanks
for having me so let's just walk through
this year who are you
mentoring for the 2018 draft it's
actually the word I choose I'm not a big
guru or whisperer guy yeah I've got
three awesome guys so Sam donal from
Southern California I met him in high
school
and worked with him for years I think
he's pretty well-documented all the
things that he's done
Josh Allen two years ago no one had
heard of now it's all everybody's
talking about kid from Fresno
you know Wyoming and I said this just
meteoric rise and then I think one of
the most interesting prospects in the
draft Kyle Allen a kid who did not get a
combine invite transferred to two
schools has a crazy story but is going
throw for throw with these guys every
single day and had about eleven private
workouts with teams who's climbing some
boards really late interesting yeah a
quarterback who's not invited to the
combine has 11 workouts yeah it's been
fascinating to watch the intrigue around
him and the more people dive into the
story then when they were come out in
person they hope that people like me
don't go on TV and talk about them okay
well then let's put a pin in that for a
moment because I do want we'll use that
as a tease for our conversation we've
got going on right now so you said you
met Sam Donald here in in in California
at high school yeah growing up when'd
you how did you get hooked up with Josh
Allen you know I had heard a bunch cuz
he decided to come out not this year the
year before and and then got rush of the
media and agents and from a tiny town
and the maturity for him to say I think
I need another year to do this and grow
and experience all these things I paid
attention to that I thought that was a
very mature decision so then I invite
him to one of my QB some accounts that I
have all offseason for high school kids
and and a lot of the top college players
and I had him and Jarrett Stidham who's
at Auburn to be out next year and stand
Arnold and they hit it off got a chance
to see it in person get to know him as a
kid and immediately identified him as
somebody I think that can help and want
to be involved with listen let's talk
about Josh a little bit because in this
crazy hamster a gerbil wheel that we
recall the talent evaluation portion of
the NFL calendar it seems like hits it's
his turn to be mentioned is the first
overall
Appl of the Cleveland Browns I right now
the knock against him is that he's
inaccurate that he's an inaccurate
thrower what do you say to that yeah I
think all these guys coming out it's
getting to the point where college
football and the NFL they're almost two
different sports the language the
verbage what they see not even just the
talent but what the quarterback is asked
to do is getting further and further
away from what an NFL quarterback is
asked to do hmm you know the play that
deshaun Watson scored on to win the
national championship that whole entire
play called was five words and yet in
the nhf in the NFL you can get h set to
gun spread right a chopped will trying
to drive every to learn mustang dragon
on a white one that's a completely
different set of skills to have and so
as these guys go through it accuracy is
one of those things where they're not
asked to make all the same type of
throws they are in the NFL so trying to
evaluate somebody's accuracy like Josh
early in college it's hard to do to
project against it in the NFL because he
didn't play with a single NFL type
receiver and he didn't really play
against any NFL DBS so it's really a
kind of a hard comp to make and the five
words that clemson used to call the play
was let's run the pick play yes I run
the pick play to the right really look
and and Watson obviously made the
transition from the five word play to
the I don't even know what the hell you
just said but but the the the the
obvious comparison for Allen and it
became even more so during our combine
coverage on the NFL Network was his
measurables were almost down to the inch
pound hundredth of a second to carson
wentz yeah i mean it was remarkable
anytime i mentioned it on the air with
Mayock sitting to my right or on the air
sitting here with folks like you to my
right I get tweets like he's inaccurate
he's not the same as Carson Wentz Carson
Wentz could throw it through a hoop he
could throw it in the window and Allen
cannot what what can you do as a mentor
not a guru or a whisperer to fix that
yeah I think mechanics when it comes to
throwing it's about being able to do the
exact same thing over and over
over again and there's always gonna be
times when you're off schedule right
when you're have to lean you're gonna
have to throw you're running for your
life but the reality is if I said I'll
give you a thousand bucks to hit a jump
shot and you can either shoot a free
throw or a fadeaway jumper from the
corner we're all gonna shoot free throws
and so how do I build a routine where
when I can I throw the ball exactly the
same every single time you know Josh was
56 percent at Wyoming the more tape I
watched the more impressed I am that he
was 56 percent why is that because
what's happening on the other side of
the throw there's two sides of it right
that's what he's doing with the ball
where he's throwing it and then there's
what's happening and so in my opinion
what happened is you've got very little
separation and you've got different
route depths and so it's really hard to
anticipate and we know some guys who
played in the NFL and had great careers
who don't have strong arms I do not
think you have to have a giant arm to be
able to play in the league but when
there's not that separation or timing
then you have to throw the ball late and
he throws the ball really hard and it's
really cold there so it ends up being
really difficult to manufacture
completions in the NFL throwing know at
me understanding the type of talent he's
gonna be around and then watching him
for the last couple months he can throw
with anticipation he can separate people
he can throw people open so it's just
gonna become a repetition thing and for
mechanics can you do it over and over
again
Jordan Palmer here on the Rich Eisen
show the layperson hearing that would
say that's an excuse making me not be
honest not if it's an evaluator might
understand that language right there
what do you think it is going on right
now with the evaluation they seen what
you were seeing or or might it just be
the idea that you're trying to cover up
for whatever this young man might lack
to be the first overall pick in this
year's draft
yeah I'll say with all these guys and
I'll say this every year moving forward
none of these guys the the jump is too
big none of these guys I don't think
I'll ever sit here and say this guy's
ready to dominate week one it's just
it's too different it's a difference it
sits on a completely different level so
you have to go alright is he accurate
enough to be a him as in any player yes
is this player after net enough to be
able to make the free-throws take all
the easy gimmies and separate and create
separation with players and is he
accurate enough to be able to throw
people open and I think when people look
at him and especially through these
private work
I think they've been able to check that
box but you also have to measure that
against who the person is right and is
this the type of person who's gonna
remain all in and constantly pursue
their careers if there's a problem they
have to fix I mean he's got the whole
all-in thing what a conversation this
has been about Josh Rosen - I don't know
you know you don't have any any stake in
that at all I do want to ask you this
question though what what is your take
on the idea that Josh Rosen might not be
all-in because a he comes from a family
of means and he doesn't really need it
be he asks why instead of saying okay
see that he might have other interests
what do you as a guy who's played in
this league and has been around a bunch
of kids and I'm sure have met Josh on
many occasions and what do you make of
that whole yeah I've been on the job
since high school actually Rahm and when
I look at Josh I see a guy who I mean
from a talent perspective I was talking
to a lot of folks in the space and and
it's pretty unanimous across the board
this guy mechanically is really clean
he's got an absolute hose
he's more athletic I think we saw it in
Indy you know some people were surprised
at the numbers
saying wow this guy's more athletic than
I thought and and I was not surprised by
that at all I think what's happened is
he's a very very capable highly
intelligent guy that's well documented
and when you're in high school in
college particularly in Los Angeles you
have a lot of opportunities to get
interested and get excited about a lot
of different things what I think's gonna
happen with Josh Rosen is once he gets
into the NFL and he does that 12 months
out of the year I think he's gonna shift
it all in I think people were right to
ask those questions and question him on
those things based off of what he's done
to date but he's the type of guy I think
once he gets into the NFL he's gonna be
see it as all-in and opportun he's gonna
realize that the twelve-month aspect of
playing quarterback and and I think he's
actually gonna dive in really lean into
that and I actually think Josh is gonna
be a phenomenal player but the idea that
that somebody can't have an interest
outside of football and still be a high
level franchise quarterback do you agree
with that no I not at all because I
think one of the things you have to be
able to do as a quarterback as a
franchise quarterback is
compartmentalized we look at Drew Brees
I mean he his he doesn't
a charity golf tournament he has a
massive foundation he also has four kids
he's an amazing father I mean like you
know as a father I know as a father like
that's not something you do on the side
and so these franchise guys I look at it
they have to be triple threats
physically mentally and emotionally and
the physical side you have to know what
to fix you have to know what to put in
your body how to take care of yourself
the mental side you have to learn all
the stuff yeah but on the emotional say
these guys are marketing for them is a
business they have to compartmentalize
that family the philanthropy what they
do in their communities and I think that
Josh being as capable as he has an
intelligence is Josh Rosen as it is is a
guy who's once he kind of grows up and
gets through the first couple years of
learning what the league throws at you I
think he'll lean into that and I think
he's gonna thrive and what about the
idea that Baker may feel can get
triggered we can get triggered that's a
red flag what are you what are you what
is your take on that Jordan you know I
think Baker is fascinating because I see
all the immaturity that's come out
that's not even opinion of mine it's
just out but at the same time I I really
honestly think that a walk-on winning
the Heisman is one of the most
impressive things were seen and earned
it it wasn't a down year it wasn't any
of those things and was up for it I
think three times so I don't know him
too well personally but I think he feeds
off positive feedback and he matches the
work ethic to be able to go and create
positive feedback by playing at a high
level and I actually think his skills do
translate with that being said you know
when people want to talk about how
there's you know Russell Wilson short
and drew Brees is short and look at them
thrive there was also 11 years between
those two guys so it's not automatic
that there's three of them every year
but I do think Baker's when those guys
you can all right Jordan Palmer let's
take a break when we come back with the
QB consultant for Kubik summit let's I
won't hit Donald yeah cuz he might be
the guy number one and if not Giants and
then if not Giants then somebody might
jump in and get him I mean there's all
sorts of fascinating things and then
Chris Brockman and I noticed something
at his pro day I don't know if you heard
us talking about it before I did big red
flag for us yeah ball count on don't
answer it now but you know you were
there in the rain ball cap water on your
eyelashes is your Achilles heel as a
quarterback
[Music]
we'll talk about that oh no next here on
this edition of the Rich Eisen show with
Jordan Palmer
give an update with jordan palmer
spending a second segment with us here
some names of players that he is
mentoring as we speak
go for it which quarterback would you
take first overall I'll start at the
bottom 15% Baker Mayfield 21% Josh Rosen
31% Sam Donald 32% Josh Allen okay so
got better today he did get better
that's the crazy thing is people are
obviously I mean that's that's how good
you are at mentoring Jordan told me now
again this is kind of the Jim Mora
question where he said and he's on our
show tomorrow that job that darn olds a
better fit in Cleveland than Josh Rosen
was and a lot of people thought that
that was maybe denigrating Rosen I'm
gonna remove that from your from your
answering Arsenal here because I know
you as a mentor you're concerned about
fit more than where they were actually
placed yeah that these guys are
absolutely both worthy of the number one
overall pick who is the better fit for
the Cleveland Browns do you think with
as much makeup turnarounds they've had
there you know if new running back new
receivers I think it's hard to look at
it plus tôt new offensive coordinator
Todd Haley mm-hm and not just Todd Haley
being a new offensive coordinator Todd
Haley's coming off of Ben Roethlisberger
who's his own person to work with and
once things done so I don't have a clear
picture of exactly what Cleveland looks
like in 2018 and I don't think anybody
really does I think that's what
Cleveland's doing right now is just
drawing the picture so it's hard to
answer that I think in terms of the
market of who's a better fit you know I
think they're both Sam and Josh Bo's
guys are both the small market I think
they thrive in a small market if people
want to say because Sam Donald's from
Los Angeles that he's you know that he's
this Southern California kid but reality
is he's from a tiny little surf
community called San Clemente that's
where he's from he happened to play at
SC Josh on the other hand is I've made
the comment to people that if Josh were
to go to Buffalo he'd be the first
first-round quarterback that was
available to go to Buffalo that him
going to Buffalo would be the biggest
city's ever lived in be a massive market
so in terms of the fit for Cleveland I
can see both those guys fitting there
you know Sam I know
has been talking about it for a long
time he's big on wanting to be the
reason that something turned around you
know and the way that his freshman year
was going at SC I think that was an
amazing feeling for him to turn that
around and rattle off eight straight and
I know that that's why he's talked a lot
about Cleveland since the beginning not
about me to go number one just about
Cleveland and for Josh you know he I
think he likes cold weather and that
says well what about the New York market
cuz both of them either one of those
guys could wind up as a giant with Eli
Manning sitting there in front of him
yeah which one do you think's a better
fit for the New York market you know I'd
say Sam is has the experience of two
years under his belt of being in Los
Angeles and what that means but at the
same time I've just watched Josh who on
paper should not be that comfortable in
the media he should be more nervous he
should be stressed out about all this
attention and all that stuff and he just
hasn't been I've been you know III
haven't known him for ten years and so I
was kind of anticipating him being
overwhelmed by the last couple of months
and everything that's happened and and
he hasn't been and so I could actually
see either of those guys fit I could see
all four of those guys fitting in a big
market obviously Baker's had so much
experience beyond the spotlight and Josh
Rosen is an L a kid from Los Angeles big
market so in terms of New York City big
market like that I can actually see all
four of those guys thriving we've got
Jordan Palmer here on the Rich Eisen
show a few more minutes left with you
darn 'old struggled in his bowl game
against Ohio State and looked to the
sidelines every single time for the play
call or for whatever's going on with an
audible and then had some issues
obviously holding on to the football
furs his his year with the USC this past
year what what how do you address those
concerns hearing hearing those are the
red flags involving for sure and there's
but there's been struggles you know I
think for any of these guys really
throughout their career I mean the none
of these guys that haven't either and he
could be number one overall here's
absolutely the I think the biggest
things you have to address with Sam
which are on tape and real this isn't
some some private stuff is ball security
in the pocket that's been an issue for
him that's not a drill I can do I'm not
going to tackle him you know in her
throwing setting with that being said
there's also a bunch of plays on
tape where he holds on the ball with one
hand and he makes somebody miss and he
runs over here sets up and throws across
the field and it's a big play so there's
a lot of risk and reward in his game as
an 18 19 and 20 year old I think as he
matures into a pro that's something that
that staff is gonna need to address it's
not about saying keep two hands on the
ball because that also says don't move
around so much and make these amazing
things happen there is a give and take
those two hold those two things hold
each other in tension and so he's got to
do a better job of mitigating that risk
in terms of even just the Ohio State
game I think we saw it two different
level programs playing I think s C's
building I think they're gonna be better
this year with the young quarterback
they have coming in but at the same time
you're watching a D line that you're
just needing two different level
programs planned I think Ohio State was
a different place a year ago again I
think s he's gonna bounce back and have
a monster year this year but so with Sam
you got a look at it you go okay is he
turning the ball over because the
spotlights too big or because he's
scared to get hit because those are two
things that are those are real issues
you should not take somebody I don't
think that's the foundation of why those
those struggles occurred I think him
being loose with the ball was him also
being creative with the ball and I think
some of the turnovers that he's had
forcing the ball in there is them having
to make a play and having to create and
that's just something you have to grow
through and we see a lot of young
quarterbacks in the NFL doing the same
thing I mean Peyton Manning how many
pics that he throws rookie year he did
it his rookie year not in college so
Sam's going through those growing pains
turns 21 in June with that being said
for a young guy he's had really good
experience of all the spotlight on him
faced a college football having to go
through those issues and I think he's
ready to come out of it and what about
our red flag here at the Rich Eisen show
they wore a ball cap in the rain was he
afraid of getting his elite here wet we
uh it was absolutely not I agree though
he's got how did he not make the the
pool for best hair well he's a reason
other redheads in there he's not no
there's no chance that he's in fair
there's no ginger contingent no no but
it's a tough he's not in the NFL yet
he's a Trista rookie he hasn't played a
snap yet okay but stop deflecting why's
this guy wearing a ball cap he's easy
afraid of getting his leaders that I've
even heard of it well there's all red
flag yeah
one else's red flag come on I made that
kid has in his hair I don't even think
it would have gotten wet it's a pomade a
red flag it's I'm just trying to figure
to see him anything you wouldn't
understand so there was a conscious
decision put the Hat on no I think he
probably just grabbed a hat that day he
actually never wears hats that's what's
funny about it
but no and in making red flag yeah s he
wanted to move the the throwing up to to
keep it from the rain and his response
was like let's just yeah we heard right
we heard that that you know who's
picking out the top of the draft you
want to not throw in the rain I mean
Josh Allen's birthday was two days later
we're sitting here going if it snows
let's go outside so the headline is that
they had the headline is that Sam Donald
is not afraid of getting his elite hair
wet no I think that the I think that's
accurate mmm I think he's perfectly fine
with all caps and then before we move on
to Kyle Allen cuz I do want to go full
circle here you said that the USC
program with its young quarterback is
going to bounce back what can you tell
me about this kid JT Daniels yeah JT
I've been you know we've been involved
with him since like seventh grade I've
never really seen anything like it
before what I've been doing the elite 11
for a long time to have somebody skip
their senior year in high school and
it'd be a good decision and he he was
Gatorade Player of the Year last year as
a junior needs four gone his senior year
of high school and I was enrolling at
USC really never seen it before how old
is he 17
he's 18 he was held back but he still
played high school football for three
years for him to do what he did and I
know it's high school football but still
just in terms of what I do for the draft
JC's have been sitting in these meetings
for three years you know it's really
cool to Sherry won Gatorade Player of
the Year and deshaun Watson as part of
his Gatorade partnership
gave him the award they threw together
for the first time five years ago
he's just been around it it's gonna be a
competition they've got some great
quarterbacks at SC if JC ends up being
the guy I think he actually I don't
think there's a ton of drop-off at the
quarterback position at SC this year and
I think Sam's
you know one of the top picks which is a
cold statement I know that and I'm gonna
be cool you guys can either make fun of
me having me back on we don't make we
don't make fun of anybody
except if they wear a ball cap in the
rain detector elite hair and it makes
sense and so who is Carl Allen I know
he's obviously fans in the state of
Texas A&M and he used to know who he is
but in terms of being on the draft radar
screen kid wasn't even at the combine
yeah I wasn't even invited because of my
involvement at the young age with these
guys I end up following these stories
around a lot and seeing the journeys
these guys go on and this was a kid it
was the top recruit in the country this
is he came out to Shaun Watson's year so
they've been they've been friends a long
time and and watching him go to A&M play
as a true freshman light it up a really
really terrible set of circumstances his
sophomore year at am leads him to
transfer to play for Tom Herman who says
you'll sit out a year and then we'll
build this really cool thing together
but Tom had to do what's right for his
family got offer at Texas you got to go
do that so we get in here it's kind of a
system where they want to run the ball
as a quarterback and here's this guy
who's an elite arm talent really really
talented and all along really what there
wasn't really a gap between him and the
other guys like it - Shaun Watson high
school and in college mmm and just was a
victim of some crazy circumstances I
paid attention to how he handled those
circumstances you know I think
quarterbacks inevitably are gonna get
faced with success and adversity and you
have to be really good at handling both
of them you can't just be good at
handling one of them and he's handled
both so well so now three months living
with Sam and Josh throwing every day on
the board together competing I mean he's
he's right there he's he's throw for
throw with these guys it's actually
better on the board they would both
agree with that and he's got a ton of
private workouts set up and he's with
somebody right now and he's a kid he's
gonna get drafted with right now come on
yeah come on he's got it got a bunch of
teams who he's been really bounced
around with you know if these narrow
zona kids so I know Arizona loves him
you know Seattle loves him the
interesting one is is nobody knows what
New England's gonna do but he's the kind
of guy they find he's the kind of guy
they go oh no one knows about him and so
that's gonna be I think what's really
fun for me on draft weekend is watching
how Kyle Allen story unfolds because
he's he's a guy he's gonna play in this
league Seattle huh
mmm that's interesting
there's one quarterback on that roster
right now that's right we're in the
market for a quarterback last draft -
it's great stuff man
thanks for coming on exam what's come
what's what's become of your mentoring
mentorship fun you know how's your
brother is he good he's doing great he
is he's gotten really gray he's like he
looks exactly like he used to just add
like 15 pounds a little bit more gray
hair and is the constant just no jacket
and beating on he'll it moved Idaho he's
let it go let it go he's done he
actually got hurt along his nickname
that I call him he got hurt and put on a
ton of weight a couple years ago not a
ton of weight but he got bigger I
started calling him Joe Carson G Carson
Palmer I call him Joe Carson how do you
like how do you like that he didn't
respond do it well but his mind's
calling chunks it was the same wow you
know as guys Jake and green ever seen
Goonies Jordan so to do a truffle
shuffle that's a request I never thought
I would make of course a partner or
jakar s'en wow that did not sit well
with him huh good luck on everything
going on with you Jordan don't be
stranger come on back anytime I know
you're down the road so to speak here in
Southern California at JW palms on
Twitter and again Jordan Palmer you can
check everything out what's the the
website is QB QB summit calm give me
someone to help some young guys on the
QB journey fantastic thanks for coming
in good luck go with your guys you got
it the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience